Wendy Williams opening up about her
health challenges that caused her to go
off air and we've got a lot to talk
about my thyroid my hyper thyroid is
attached also to Graves disease Graves
disease squeezes the muscles behind your
eyeballs after Wendy took a three-week
hiatus due to her battle with
hyperthyroidism and Graves disease it
was just it just a mess going on inside
of my body but I'm saying the TV
personality sat down for her first TV
interview airing on Good Morning America
before she returned to her hosting
duties on Monday to be back nice to be
missed
thank you so much for waiting Wendy
admits she cried when doctors instructed
her to take nearly a month off from work
but it turns out it was the best
prescription ever because I met a great
team they gave me a full like a full
workup I found out that I was very
deficient in vitamin D my internist told
me I am if not the worst case of
deficient vitamin D that she's ever seen
in her career now she's making her
health a priority and encouraging her
viewers to do the same we take care of
everybody but ourselves I'm not doing
that anymore Amy that's a first
[Music]
[Applause]